[Music]
and super stocker news I'm sure there's
a lot of stalkers you got bad that are
out there no I think I'm too freaky and
they're like ah what about that one mm
the army that always stopped by your
store
that's a stalker oh you're also too tall
like a lot of stalkers are shorts i'ma
[ __ ] you really I didn't know that like
you know insecure and stuff so really I
mean I mean that's how people getting
stalkers have been at least that's how
they're good at climbing trees that's it
Joe they're like a little monkey what's
it like to be admired in that type of
way that's what I call them in mine no I
want to make somebody so horn adjust my
exist oh gee oh you do have stalkers
remember in the girl chat like people
that send you like crazy messages she's
some crazy girl stalkers too we were
sharing our crazy messages that we get I
want examples like what what does it
feel like to be the girl that is it okay
I want to dress you in a diaper and
smell your cards like some [ __ ] like
that it's like crazy I thought it was
gonna be like I really love you I miss
you so much type of there's that too but
that's like like that's like
dime-a-dozen basics [ __ ] don't those
are the ones that'll get your attention
on those there's committed ones that's
like I'm gonna get this bitch's
attention they're like I want to
duct-tape each one of your toes and then
slowly peel it off like so weird [ __ ]
that sounds really relaxing it does
actually yeah I wouldn't mind that yeah
so what if you're that one girl I don't
get the attention you're like that was
just doesn't check DNZ doesn't check her
DM she doesn't put any post stuff she
had an obsessed weirdo that kept [ __ ]
attacking her like maybe that's why her
stalkers a hater [ __ ] they're hating
her because she's with me oh also with
some jealous ass yeah they don't like
that she's diluting the white race oh
those type of people okay
Wow I would think it would be the more
the opposite like the Japanese ones that
don't like that she's diluting the
Japanese right now they don't care
they're like please take him take him
take him
he already take him out yeah he's making
us downgrade all right submit it by
favorite snack go do my Cheetos Hot
Cheetos
oh yeah and hot rice I like fruit takis
ha what the big stick popsicles you know
nice cream consumers like this buxom
that's such a fat question but last
night like we're at the studio and then
means we went to go get some pizzas eat
Dave's like I can't do it man like I'm
on a diet I already had dinner today
yeah you were talking about this pizza
yeah he was like did you get it's this
place called no ho pizza it's just
pretty bombed oh yeah I think it's one
of the best pizzas in LA he is like I
can't do it it went from that to why
don't we just order a whole pizza but
then you guys eat it I'm gonna just have
one slice yeah more than
you are misquoting the story I had two
slices you took a bite of the third one
then I also ate the buffalo chicken
7-eleven and a taquito roll it was a
cheat days it was a cheap for the whole
month I know we already had dinner
yeah that's what you saying I ate so
much I'm full right now I can't eat at
all this [ __ ] guy every time we're in
the studio every [ __ ] time were in
the studio he has to get jack-in-the-box
yes it gets like McDonald's or some [ __ ]
even for my [ __ ] fat face cuz I get
hungry because we go late into the night
you know hungry because I'm so skinny
Hey last time I did a good job you
should eat before you see him why can't
you do that you stupid son of a [ __ ]
was so good alright an extreme stalker
has a family's home bombarded with
random people every day wow that's kind
of interesting though jamie has a whole
following where he has like an army like
yeah I mean it's weird because it's a
lot of different types of people ranging
from like contractors who are there that
they're like hey we got a call to fix
your pipes and then there's like
crackheads that are like hey you got the
[ __ ] and like random ass people sure is
an Indian family like there's a free TV
up to 20 people per day arrived saying
they were called to provide electrical
plumbing or some that are seeking
illegitimate business some of them a lot
of them have police records they're
criminals they're felons they have
active warrants for their arrests why
did they do this for I don't it doesn't
say like he says the guy who's getting
stalked he's it has a family there and
everything is just a family residence he
even had to put up this big fat sign
because like because people were coming
over so much so there's like this sign
this is what I could say alert what if
you have been asked to provide any
services to this address such as carto
home repair locksmith plumbing food
deliveries or anything else please call
the North Salt Lake police at the number
to make a report we are all victim
of this cuts in Utah they had to get
this professional sign man what if he
ordered post mates and they read and
they go away oh that's true he probably
can't get any service now no his name is
Walt Gilmore in case you want to go he
could still probably get to cuz if the
stalker was like hey I put a sign out
there saying like alert um but just
ignore cuz I really need your help
that's true if it was a smart stalker so
this the calls the police are tracing
like the calls because they're all
coming from the same like area yeah
number and area and he's coming from
Hawaii Hawaii yeah the guy doesn't even
live in Utah lazy over there well he
doesn't have to go very far I just pick
up the phone or answer even get out of
this storm I don't know other than like
he says after he does it he just goes
because I was actually watching this
news story are very similar to this
about this family that kept getting like
I guess the supposed to went out on
Craigslist that was like hey I want to
have free sex while my husband's not
home and she would get like a bunch of
guys that would come over and she's like
I didn't put that up and like it was
this guy's wife and it was a family that
lived there and they were like I hope
you don't know who's doing this and then
like on Valentine's Day everybody got a
Valentine's Day card from the husband
and those wives husbands were like what
the [ __ ] man he's like I didn't send
those and it turned out to be this lady
who wanted to buy that house and that
couple got it instead of her and she's
like I felt like it was my house and I
can't believe that they have it so she
wanted to like scare them out of living
there I would [ __ ] find where that
[ __ ] lives and I would talk to her she
lives in prison now so
that's why Sam I wonder what kind of
Hawaiian did he anger um it doesn't say
it just says that or they might just be
using like a phone that has a 808 area
case it could be that too but I think
the the guy who lives here he has a
feeling he knows who the person is he
doesn't give the reason for why it must
have been that hotel staff I [ __ ] over
when I went to Oahu yeah that's probably
what happened yeah that's it or the taxi
driver I didn't tip his wife's really
scared
constantly other family members don't
like to go outside because they don't
know who's coming it's very threatening
it's not only threatening to his family
but his entire neighborhood this guy is
like paying money then to these people
with dissenter no actually the police
estimate a combined loss to companies is
more than $20,000 in wages and
uncollected fees because that people
show up and then they're like we didn't
ask so they're happy if he has like a
clue of who it might be I'm hoping that
they gave that information to the cop
have an idea I have an idea one of the
cause was about there was a fake call
that said that his house was flooding
and the false call cost the company an
estimate $4,000 to round up workers to
drive to the house rather get beat up
than to do this cuz what do you do at
that point I don't even pick up the
phone I hate answering the door yeah
when I hear knocks on the door I'm like
oh I will pretend that I'm not hold I
thought I thought this stalker guy was
hiring people to act like they're
plumbers like that'd be so much my foot
here same guy shows up every day yeah
did you call the plumbing spirits
they're using voice recognition software
to try to find the substance with
suspects and they took out a civil
stalking injunction against a person
that they believe is responsible but
there are multiple suspects and they're
not ruling anybody out so the person
they believe is responsible is in Hawaii
but it could be a number I was just
kidding I don't want a stalker yeah it's
all fun look at you do bragging a [ __ ]
that's gonna get multiple my stalker he
didn't
this though he didn't go all big I think
I'm too abrasive what for people don't
want to so that person was following you
physically he yeah he would show up at
my I worked at a restaurant and so he
would always show up and request me and
I had given made the mistake of giving
him my number cuz I was 616 and I had
given him my number because make a lot
of mistakes dude but early I get Hawaii
you you followed the guy and you almost
got but ring OH under 20 I was under 20
all of you let him buy your ice cream
yeah well I didn't have Geppetto move I
told you I didn't have friends to learn
things festival you ought to live in
Santa Barbra dude you would've been
killed everywhere else
I know it's very sheltered there if
someone bought me ice cream I would have
been sold right and it was just like oh
I'm away from my parents and I mama oh I
feel like if you guys came back they
give you ice could you be like do I suck
you off or what walking next to him like
Hank yeah so Gary's like dripping all
over your shirt oh my god
that's a deep throat I wasn't like a
bikini top because it was Hawaii oh my
god did [ __ ] me looking back I'm like
how did you not know but like at the
time I was so innocent I was like mom
there's a future about strangers crazy
like that
no she taught me but in my head I was
like I'm learned you know I can talk to
this guy he's nice oh god did I never
want a daughter how old was this guy in
Hawaii
he was like late 30s like he was a big
old guy too and I was just like you
could have ran out yeah he didn't look
like a bad guy yeah they usually don't
they don't show up well I got iPads I
know the t-shirt that says I'm a bad
yeah a guy that looks like that tells me
he's desperate for [ __ ] and Yetta
he had an accent like a Louisiana accent
I was like those southern boys they're
not oh you just looked at him you're
like mmm he has no curly mustache and
he's not next to a railroad track you're
not like a cartoon hello yeah
[Music]